students marching in Indonesia's capital
and several other cities on Tuesday
calling on the government to halt
controversial legislation being debated
in Parliament last week the government
passed a law to amend the power of the
corruption eradication Commission this
week Parliament planned to make changes
to a pending criminal code bill which
could discriminate against religious
minorities outlawed sex outside marriage
ban abortion and make it illegal to
insult the president but the outcry by
protesters forced a delay students
fought with police outside parliament in
jakarta security forces responded with
tear gas and water cannon to disperse
the crowds I think there are so many
problems weakening of the
anti-corruption Commission and then
rushing to pass the Criminal Code they
want to pass other bills too before the
Parliament term ends but there is no
transparency as a tear gas cleared the
cleanup began riot police and ambulances
remain on standby for protests around
Parliament there's a clear message left
behind this graffiti says we are aunty
Parliament and down below it says you're
violating the people's rights the
students here say they'll continue this
fight until there's change for decades
previous Indonesian governments have
tried to change laws that were
established under Dutch colonial rule
president Joko Widodo revived discussion
when he was elected four years ago human
rights groups say the latest proposed
changes are anterior fullest for the
last 20 years Indonesia have gone
through a reform process in which the
agenda on corruption eradication a human
rights protection have had tremendous
achievement the law will roll back all
reforms in Indonesia in the field of
human rights and human rights in an
anti-corruption analysts believe this is
why politicians are pushing to create
Indonesia's own criminal code but the
political fallout could threaten
president Joko Widodo spreadability he
was a president who writes on the public
support who is
riding on the wave of the public support
from the very beginning but now he is
turning against the public that means
that he will be viewed by the public as
more being for the elites for the
political parties and so on and so forth
concerns are growing that the pending
criminal code will be introduced when
the new parliament is sworn in next week
protesters say they will continue to
make sure their voices are heard Rahila
mohammed al jazeera jakarta